economía en directo américa de francia
24 estaba conmigo en el estudio la
señorita daniela blandón daniela
bienvenida buena mañana de martes vamos
a empezar hablando de naciones unidas
porque hoy como ya lo estábamos
comentando también inicia esta asamblea
general número 77 y 238 organizaciones
civiles enviaron un mensaje así es raúl
caballero raúl muy buenos días es una
representante de una asociación civil en
yemen habló en nombre de 238 firmantes
de una carta abierta dirigida a la onu
en la que advierten que cada cuatro
segundos muere una persona de hambre en
el mundo aseguran también que a 882 mil
sufren de lo que denominan hambre
catastrófica la misiva agrega que
algunas comunidades de 45 países ya
sufren de crisis alimentaria agravada
por supuesto por la pandemia y la guerra
en ucrania y finalizan con que 345
millones de personas en el mundo sufren
niveles agudos de hambre el doble de lo
que había antes de la pandemia del 19
precisamente raúl se espera que en el
marco de esta asamblea se desarrolló una
cumbre sobre seguridad alimentaria bueno
daniela este próximo tema va a inflar a
lo que las personas no le gustan las
cripto monedas porque porque hubo un
nuevo robo un nuevo robo en estas
plataformas ni a usted ni a mí nos gusta
escribir o maneras de esto pues aumenta
entonces nuestro rechazo por lo menos
somos muy cautelosos a la hora de
invertir con esos cripto activos que no
están vigilados esta vez el robo ocurrió
en reino unido a la firma de comercio de
cripto monedas él se llama winter merckx
con sede en londres y protagoniza
entonces el más reciente atraco en una
industria plagada de esta clase de
delitos cibernéticos la noticia la dio
por su la noticia la dio su propio
fundador y siguió identificado en
twitter como efe johnny gay boy quien
trino hemos sido pirateados por
alrededor de 160 millones de dólares en
nuestras operaciones y después agregó si
usted tiene dinero en winter news
nuevamente somos solventes pero si se
sienten más seguros recuperando esa
inversión absolutamente podemos hacerlo
hablemos dani entonces del riesgo de
usar esta plataforma tampoco vamos a
satanizar las pero pues si tienen
riesgos claro que sí claro que sí el
objetivo de estas plataformas los
softwares descentralizados es
proporcionar servicios financieros
basados en cripto monedas sin los
guardianes tradicionales como lo son los
bancos o las autoridades gubernamentales
pero han sido blancos de numerosos
atracos en los últimos años ya que el
sector está poco regulado como lo
mencionábamos y en casos como éste no
hay ante quien acudir para reclamar
dinero muy internet se autodenomina uno
de los jugadores más grandes en los
cripto mercados globales dice que
administra cientos de millones en
activos y que comercializa más de cinco
mil millones de dólares por día pero
nadie puede dar fe de ello más allá de
su propio fundador cuyo nombre en
twitter en realidad es wexford séneca
que traduciría algo así como un cínico
esperanzado como un cínico o ambición
viciosa usted metería su plata en una
cuenta
no se llama no invertiría en quilín y
comunidades creo y menos y la persona se
llama de ese único ambicioso dan y vamos
a francia porque se manifestaron los
trabajadores
domiciliarios los trabajadores que
reparten no sé y raúl el sindicato cgt
convocó una manifestación de apoyo a los
trabajadores de las plataformas de
reparto en parís por otro stand por las
condiciones laborales también por las
tarifas pero también para pedir la
regularización de estos trabajadores que
estuvieron en primera línea durante los
peores momentos de la pandemia y que
ahora dicen que se han convertido en
personas no gratas en el país ya que las
plataformas desconectan cientos de
cuentas cada semana dicen ellos
desafiando la legislación laboral cuál
es el juego de estas plataformas esto
nos lo explica nuestro equipo en parís
hace seis meses que además ya no tiene
derecho de trabajar para über its
intenté conectarme pero no pude dos días
después de recibir un correo electrónico
diciendo que mis papeles eran
fraudulentos y no eran válidos para una
cuenta de entregado
una desconexión sin indemnización ni
derecho al subsidio por desempleo
administre que sus papeles no estaban en
regla pero se sorprende de que über its
haya tardado cuatro años en realizarlos
durante del cob y no nos pidieron los
papeles nos dejaron trabajar como indios
señalamientos y presión del gobierno
über al igual que otras plataformas
decidió limpiar las cuentas de los
repartidores el resultado 2500
desconexiones de cuentas este verano
solo en la plataforma estadounidense con
la misma justificación los papeles
aportados son fraudulentos a mitú sigue
teniendo derecho a trabajar pero no se
deja engañar según él la plataforma
pretende cumplir con la legislación pero
sin cambiar realmente su funcionamiento
los próximos documentos que no eran
fraudulentos hace un año hace dos años
no es hoy que lo dirán y lo que es
inaceptable ub reactiva otras cuentas
con estos mismos documentos oroville
ante la polémica jugar emitió un
comunicado para justificar estas
desconexiones pero rechaza cualquiera
entrevista ante la cámara esta situación
no sorprende aquí sin moción abogado
especializado en derecho laboral
la plataforma se aprovecha de esto sabe
muy bien que existe esa población que
lleva meses y meses trabajando pero
cierra los ojos porque es la gente que
necesita para trabajar a bajo coste
porque si volviera a una población con
papeles no con tanta gente para trabajar
a ese precio
así que cierra los ojos las demandas se
multiplican para intentar cambiar las
cosas pero estás solo en manos del
gobierno a hacerse el de la vista gorda
o regular de una vez por todas esta
situación cómo están los mercados ahora
ni el raúl esta semana la reunión de dos
días de la reserva federal que inicia
hoy se lleva todas las miradas pero lo
invito a que hagamos énfasis en las
farmacéuticas que tuvieron una muy mala
jornada el lunes las acciones de los
fabricantes de vacunas se desplomaron
después de que el presidente de eeuu joe
biden dijera en una entrevista
televisada que la pandemia del cob y de
19 había terminado moderna no guagua
xxxiv hay un tec cayeron entre el 6 y el
8 por ciento dependiendo del caso y
freezer perdió un 1,24 por ciento
borrando así miles de millones de
dólares en capitalización bursátil en un
solo día en europa pues las bolsas se
mueven con mesura a la espera de esta
probable alza de tasas de interés que
hará la reserva federal el miércoles en
alemania los inversionistas están
atentos a lo que suceda con el
suministro de gas natural de cara al
invierno ya que el regulador estatal
aseguró que lleno en un 90% su capacidad
de almacenamiento y necesita un 95% el
primero de noviembre para que no haya
racionamientos cifra del día para
finalizar este primer bloque económico
de la mañana te va a gustar es el que le
gustan los carros lujosos se encantan 75
mil millones de euros ese es el valor de
mercado objetivo que se trazó la icónica
marca de autos deportivos porsche para
su salida en bolsa en alemania el
próximo 29 de septiembre la de esta
subsidiaria de volkswagen es el segundo
fabricante de automóviles más grande del
mundo podría ser la tercera oferta
pública inicial más grande de europa y
había sido aplazada por la guerra nunca
na también por la turbulencia que eso
causó en los mercados o comprar acciones
entonces si quieres comprar acciones
para un carro pero si una acción por lo
menos por lo menos ahí si me alcanza un
poco
danny como siempre gracias por toda la
información más adelante más economía
pasamos a salvar a las mentes con toda
la información